hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
episode I'm going to answer a question
from one of my youtube viewers Michael
who wrote in asking if it's worth
getting a higher degree of education and
if that would help him sell more to his
customers because they see him more as
an authority so Michael there's a number
of reasons to go and get higher
education I don't think it would really
help you with your customers so if you
wanted to learn the knowledge that's
great if you want to make more
connections get more experience and
maybe that would be a good reason to do
it but in terms of being able to sell
your customers because you have a degree
I don't think that's really going to
help you much in most situations as a
quick example my first company that did
well was a biotech software company and
I was in charge of sales those 19 years
old I was in University just doing an
undergrad program and we were selling to
universities we were selling to NASA and
johnson Johnson as well big corporations
and we were selling software to
researchers so you think they would care
a lot about you know who's selling this
stuff but it never really came up like
they care about the results customers
care about results not so much about the
prestige of who's selling them so I
don't think that's really going to make
an impact in terms of you be able to
sell more customers they're going to
care about your ability to deliver what
you say you're going to do there are
other reason to go out and get the
education again if you're looking for
those skills look at the improve your
knowledge you're going to make
connections in the industry then those
could be reasons but I wouldn't do it
just to add more prestige for selling
more to customers so I hope that helps
Michael I'd love to hear what you guys
have to think if you agree or disagree
with me please leave a comment below if
you like the video please give it a
thumbs up those things always make me
want to make more videos and add some no
excitement to my day so thank you for
that and we'll see you in the next
episode
you